just when you thought you were done with
Chad Johnson's antics on the
Bachelorette
this season's villain strikes again
you're welcome
Here I am Chad shared this Instagram
collage on Monday kissing up on fellow
contestant Robbie Hayes ex-girlfriend
hope Higginbottom some men in the house
claimed that Robbie broke up with hope
just to come on the show Ravi is a lying
fake person and she deserves the truth
and the caption chat explains while
travelling this weekend our paths cross
and I finally had the opportunity to
meet hope Higginbottom in person let me
just say she is even more beautiful in
person a great girl like her deserves so
much better than someone who lies cheats
and ends a four year long relationship
in order to pursue Fame on a TV show
you're amazing I miss you already
Robbie still has pics with his axe on
his Instagram his most recent photo of
the two was posted on November 5th when
they celebrated her birthday in Italy
though clearly Robbie's now all about
Jojo